prince andrew is the second son of queen
elizabeth ii and ninth in the line to
the british throne
but after accusing him of rape and
sexual abuse
virginia jeffrey says she no longer
wants him to be protected by his power
and position
the australian american has filed a
lawsuit in new york
accusing the royal of sexually abusing
her when she was a teenager in a
statement she said
i hope that other victims will see that
it is possible not to live in silence
and fear but to reclaim one's life by
speaking out and demanding justice
jeffrey says she was trafficked for sex
by jeffrey epstein he's a convicted sex
offender who took his own life in a new
york jail cell in august 2019
a month after he was arrested on child
sex trafficking charges
jeffrey says epstein forced her to have
sex with his friends including prince
andrew on three occasions in 2001 in
london new york and on epson's private
island
flight logs released after epstein's
death show that jeffrey was with prince
andrew at the time of the alleged
assaults jeffrey was pictured with the
prince and galen maxwell who's in jail
in the u.s awaiting trial on charges of
recruiting grooming and sexually abusing
underage girls as young as 14 for
epstein and she went on to have sex with
you in a house in belgravia belonging to
guerlain maxwell didn't happen in a 2019
interview prince andrew firmly denied
all allegations he also couldn't
recollect having met jeffrey
a year later and after a public backlash
andrew resigned from all public roles
buckingham palace has not responded to
jeffrey's lawsuit but in the past it's
firmly denied the allegations against
the prince as categorically untrue
jeffrey has been one of the most
outspoken women to accuse prince andrew
and epstein of sexual abuse
the fbi has been investigating the
claims but jeffrey is now suing the
prince in a civil case
she hopes to get justice
saying the damage from the abuse was
severe and lasting
laura about manly al
jazeera let's get more on this story
with paul brennan live for us in london
hello there paul can prince andrew
actually be extradited to answer these
allegations
there are conflicting legal opinions on
this i have to say the overwhelming
consensus is that he can't at the moment
and there's a couple of reasons for that
uh understand the understanding of the
american legal system is that criminal
proceedings uh have to complete before
any civil case can proceed on the same
allegations and in this particular case
of course federal investigators and
federal prosecutors are still looking at
the gelane maxwell allegations
jeffrey epstein's case uh criminal case
obviously fell by the way uh after he
died in prison in 2019 uh but gulen
maxwell remains on bail um and is her
case is very much active uh the other
thing is that although prince andrew
does not enjoy diplomatic immunity
um
[Music]
it is it is very much felt that that he
he would not uh
be required it's not a felony case it's
not a criminal case this is a civil case
uh brought by jennifer uh and as a
result
extradition doesn't seem to apply in
this case so that's the that's the
consensus of the legal opinions that
we've been hearing this morning
what about in the court of public
opinion though
paul what what's been the public's
reaction
well it's obviously massive news uh here
in the uk i have to say that the uh
important a-level examination results
these are exam results for 18 year olds
which dictate whether they go on to
university they've been released today
and they're they're the top story
that said uh prince andrew's predicament
is certainly second story and it's being
it's headline news around the world as
well
as far as the court of public opinion
goes frankly well it's second trending
story on twitter here in the uk on
social media
it's pretty high up in reddit as well
the aggregator of uh the internet's
front pages and conversations and
opinions seem to be well spread across
the whole kaleidoscope there's many
people who have uh a massive amount of
of sympathy uh for jennifer roberts and
and her status as a victim
there's also a lot of uh
sympathy for the queen in all of this
you know prince andrew was said to be
her favorite son and his fall from grace
uh has no doubt pained the royal family
and the queen in particular and so
there's a lot of public sympathy for the
queen in all of this and the other
overriding sentiment is that look if
prince andrew who has denied any uh
impropriety if he really has nothing to
hide then he should cooperate with
prosecutors and and with this case
that's the other third strand of public
opinion that i'm detecting as a distinct
sort of trail
it's going to be fascinating to see how
it turns out thank you for that update
paul brennan live for us in london